(click)
(beeping)
(inspirational techno music)
- What I'm gonna try to do
is to tell you what the challenge is
and how far we've gotten.
First of all, this diagram,
which Pat Churchland and I first published
in our book in 1992,
The Computational Brain,
illustrates the real difficulty here,
because there's 11 orders
of spacial magnitude
between molecules down
here at the very bottom
and the entire central nervous system
that gives rise to behavior
up at the very top at the meter of scale.
And we've heard talks today
at every one of these levels.
We've heard about hormones,
the important impact that they have
on remodeling the brain,
especially during adolescence.
Synapses, we've heard that pruning
may be of critical importance,
both in the development
and then degeneration.
So that's clearly very important,
and understanding how the molecules
at the synapses in particular
are responsible for
maturation is critical.
We know that there are
changes occurring in networks.
For example, we heard
about the impact of sound
on the maturation of a
baby's auditory system
and how important that was
for being able to later
have normal language
and learning ability.
If you can't hear properly,
then it's very difficult to
know what people are saying,
and especially if you
start going to school,
it puts you at a great disadvantage.
We heard about the brain imaging,
the important technique that allows us
to tap into large scale
patterns of brain activity.
But how do you jump from
these large scale patterns
way up here, global activity,
down all the way through all
the systems and the maps?
We heard about visual system
is a sequence of maps from
primary visual cortex,
dozens, up to the very higher areas
that are responsible for being
able to recognize objects.
How are we gonna connect the dots
between all these areas?
That's really the challenge.
And it's not gonna be necessarily
jumping from molecules to CNS,
although we'd always like the magic pill
that is targeting a specific molecule
and then hoping that that
will solve everything.
I don't think that's a good model.
The fact that we've had
how many clinical trials
for Alzheimer's that have failed
in the last two or three years
is at least a dozen trials
saying that amyloid plaque by itself,
getting rid of it isn't necessarily
the way to solve the problem.
Now there's something missing from this,
and I have to say that
there's a lot missing from it,
but just from today's talks
I think you've heard that we have to add
at least one more type
of cell to this diagram.
Half the cells in your
brain are glial cells,
and in particular there's the astrocytes.
We've heard a lot about the microglia.
The oligdendrocytes are
very important, too,
because they're the ones
that wrap around the axons
and they speed the action
potential down the axons.
That has to do with timing,
and so we really have to
put them front and center
if we're gonna especially understand
something about when things go wrong.
Now when I was young,
I was told that space
is the final frontier
from watching Star Trek.
(audience laughs)
But I now come to believe
that the final frontier
is going to be time,
understanding how the temporal processing
occurring in different circuits
and delays that occur
between communication,
between different parts of the brain,
may be critically important.
We've neglected it,
so I've worked on networks
for my entire career,
and I've always thought of networks
as being the tightly
interconnected group of neurons,
typically in the cortex,
a single neuron connecting
to 10,000 neighbors,
and in a single column 100,000 neurons,
and that adds up to at the end
billions of synapses in a single column.
But there's another kind of network,
and that's a communication network.
A communication network
is the one that extends,
broadcasts the signals in
your cell phones, right,
are being broadcast through
a communication network,
and the brain has one that
is just as sophisticated
as anything that we've ever come across.
But I want to take you
back to the early days
when Carla was a young puppy,
or young kitten, I guess.
I'm not sure what would be
the proper way of putting it,
which he made a very important (laughs),
sorry, Carla.
(audience laughs)
It was a very important observation
about traveling waves in the retina.
The reason why it's
important is that these occur
even before the eye opens,
so there's dynamic patterns of activity
that are already spreading
through the retina.
And here you can see,
this is now from a more recent paper,
but this from an array of electrodes
that are put on the retina
that's slapped down.
And these are the action potentials
coming from the ganglion cells.
And you can see over seconds
this wave of activity
sweeps across the retina.
Now, why is that interesting?
Well, it turns out that these waves
are giving a temporal structure
to the action potentials
going up to the next stage
in the lateral geniculate,
and it's essential for
getting that pathway
wired up properly, being able to sort out
the input from the two eyes, first of all,
'cause the waves are independent,
but secondly is
information about location,
because as the wave spreads
from one location to the next,
the action potentials arrive
one position to the next,
and that helps sort out the map in LGN
and ultimately into the cortex.
Now, very recently,
we discovered waves in
the cerebral cortex,
global waves, unbelievably
large scale patterns of activity
that we still don't understand
the significance of,
although I have a pretty good hypothesis,
and they occur while you are sleeping.
When you go to sleep, you
go through several stages
from awake down to deep slow wave sleep,
but on the way, you go through stage two.
It's called intermediate sleep,
and it's characterized
by these sleep spindles.
These are bursting activity
that originates in the thalamus,
projects to the cortex.
They are 10 to 14 hertz.
They last one or two seconds.
They recur every five seconds.
And there are some people who spend
up to half of the night
in this slow wave sleep
during which the spindles are occurring.
Now, I've done some very
detailed biophysical modeling,
so I can tell you precise mechanisms
that give rise to the spindles.
It's a bursting.
It has to do with new ion
channels that are uncovered
when the cells hyper-polarize.
It means that membrane
potential goes down.
But what I would've never
guessed is how the activity
between the thalamus and
the cortex organizes itself.
In the textbooks, what you
hear is that it's synchronous.
That is to say it occurs
the same place in the cortex
at exactly the same time.
And it is approximately synchronous.
But I wanted to let
you decide for yourself
how synchronous it really is.
So this is an array of electrodes,
eight by eight, 64 electrodes,
that have been placed on
the surface of the cortex
in an epilepsy patient who
has gone to the hospital
with a form of epilepsy
that can't be treated with any drugs.
And so what they have to
do is isolate the focus
so they can go in and take it out
and hopefully keep that person
from having seizures again.
So here is the electrodes.
And by the way, they
have these electrodes in
for about a week waiting
for a seizure to occur,
so it's a fantastic opportunity
for someone like me,
a neuroscientist, who wants
to ask fundamental questions
about a human brain,
about things like language
for which there is no other model system.
Okay, so what we've done
is color each in gray,
from white to black, as
you can see, the amplitude.
And this is the one that
you're gonna see here in red,
is this one, but all the other electrodes
are gonna be represented that way,
and I want you just to
follow the white dots
and tell me what pattern they form.
This is going around once
every 70 milliseconds, right?
So this is going around
at roughly 14 hertz.
And you can see as it goes up and down.
So did everybody see what I saw?
It's a rotating, circular,
traveling wave, and it's global.
It goes from, as you can see,
it goes from the temporal
cortex to the parietal cortex
up to the prefrontal cortex.
And if you look at the pattern
on the side of my head,
this should remind of you Princess Leia.
(audience laughs)
So this occurs thousands
of times during the night.
What is it doing?
We think it has something to
do with synaptic plasticity,
because the timing is just
right for something called
spike-time-dependent plasticity.
And so it may be that,
we know there's replay
from the hippocampus during the night.
It's called memory consolidation,
and it occurs over many, many nights,
and this might be the mechanism.
So we have a really great opportunity here
to actually explore it.
Now, we know that there
are long range connections
between different parts of the cortex,
these are called association fibers,
and also across between the hemispheres.
And it's really these that we think
are carrying the time delayed signals.
And it may be that these time
delays are really important,
getting them right.
We know that in, for example,
traumatic brain injury
when soldiers come back
from the Middle East
with traumatic problems with traumas,
they often have problems with
concentration and attention,
and concussions on football
players and so forth,
and when you look in the brain with MR,
the only thing you can find
are little spots in the white matter.
So, it could well be that the white matter
is really important for
integrating globally
all the information in
different parts of the cortex,
and it could be that by
strengthening connections
between these distant areas
through spindles or some other mechanism
that we're able to connect
up all the different parts
of the sensory cortices and association
in the prefrontal cortex.
Now, the timing is also, obviously,
very important in the auditory cortex
and in the motor systems.
So this is, I think, something
that hasn't been explored.
We focus so much on the gray matter
and not so much on the white matter.
There are some really
intriguing observations that
when learning takes place,
it's not just the synapses
that change their strength,
the volume of the white matter changes.
How could that be?
Well, the oligodendrocytes
that wrap around the axons
change the speed.
So maybe what's happening
is you're adjusting
the timing of the spike as it goes across
these large scale connections
between different parts of the cortex.
That's all speculative,
but I think it really means
we have to start looking
carefully at the axons
as well as the dendrites.
Now, I'm gonna play a science
fiction movie for you.
It's animated, but it's based
on the connections we see,
and it also gives you,
you'll see an impression
of the activity that might be taking place
within the cortex.
So these little white flashes
are actually action potentials, spikes,
going down the axons that you just saw
between these different cortical areas.
And this gives you an
impression of what it might be
if you could actually see into your brain,
the person sitting next to you,
and actually see what they're thinking
or what they're seeing or
what it is that they're doing
in terms of their motor system.
Every single thought
is gonna be represented
by some pattern of activity
in some part of your brain,
and specifically in different
parts of the cortex.
Now, right now this is
science fiction for the human,
but, on April 2nd, 2013,
Obama announced this grand initiative.
These grand initiatives only
occur once every decade or two,
and when they do, it really has an impact,
and it has had a huge impact
on the neuroscience community
over the last three years.
The key letters, by the
way, in the acronym IN
is innovative neurotechnology.
And I have to say that our
sponsors, the Kavli Foundation,
were critically important
in bringing this opportunity
to the notice of the White House.
And Miyoung Chun in
particular was the spark plug
who actually got the thing off the ground,
so we really owe the Kavli Foundation
a great debt of gratitude.
But what's happened
since this announcement
is really astonishing,
because new tools and
techniques are coming online
that are accelerating research
by orders of magnitude,
and let me give you one example.
And this is not science fiction.
This is real.
This, you are seeing a
zebra fish larval brain.
You could see, it's only
a millimeter or so across.
It contains about 80,000 neurons.
It has a genetic marker that
will light the neuron up
when it's activated.
So here's a neuron, here's
a neuron, here's a neuron.
These are the ones that are firing
at this particular moment in time,
and this is looking at it from below,
from above, from the
front, and from the side.
We can record from all the neurons
at the same time from this brain.
And I'm gonna play a
movie just to prove that.
Now, I hate to tell you this.
This zebra fish larva
is just sitting there.
It's immobilized, and
there's no sensory input.
There's no light.
So what you're seeing is
called spontaneous activity.
But every once in a while,
the spontaneous activity,
the pattern changes, like right there.
What's happening?
Something happened in the
brain of the zebra fish
that is unrelated to anything
that the zebra fish is
experiencing or is actually moving.
But it's really clear,
to me, at least, that we don't
understand the first thing.
(audience laughs)
It's a Chinese curse, "May
you get what you wish for,"
and this is something we've always wanted,
to be able to have access
to all of the neurons
and the activity occurring.
For all we know,
this is what the zebra
fish does when it thinks.
What do you do when you go to bed at night
and you're sitting there, right?
There's no sensory input
coming, you're not moving,
but thoughts go through your head, right?
So that's gotta be represented somewhere,
so this is getting tools and techniques
that allow us to decode
what those patterns are
is really the challenge.
And we're very fortunate
that tools and techniques
are coming online exactly
when we needed them.
It's called machine learning,
and there's a meeting that's
been held for the last 30 years
called Neural Information
Processing Systems, NIPS,
and the next meeting will be
held in Barcelona next week.
6,000 people will show up.
At the first meeting, there were 600,
so that's a factor of 10 greater.
And every single high tech
company is showing up to recruit.
And why?
It turns out that these
tools and techniques
that have been developed
and have been inspired by the brain,
the N is neural, it turns out have
fantastic applications in the real world.
You've heard about deep learning.
Well, deep learning came
from this NIPS community.
And, those same tools and
techniques can be used
for understanding those
patterns of activity
that you just saw, for analyzing
large scale recordings,
for working out the
detailed wiring diagram
called connectomics, and
for quantifying behavior.
It turns out that we can go way beyond
the simple having an animal press a button
with having it move around freely,
and this can be done
automatically and scored.
And it's been done on flies,
it's been done on mice.
They have a sequence of
stereotyped behavior.
They groom themselves and so forth.
And interestingly, on humans.
We can now detect and automatically score
your facial expressions.
Like, we saw some pictures
of the fearful face.
Well, we've worked with Paul Ekman,
and we've developed
these deep learning tools
to actually be able to
do that automatically,
and we can detect these
fleeting moments of expression
across your face.
They're called micro-expressions,
and they're very telling,
because they're brain leaks.
They're feelings you're having
inside that leak through,
and you may not even be
aware of 'em yourself,
but they can be picked up now,
and that can be a way
that we can understand
a little bit more about the
internal state of your brain.
Okay, so I just wanna end
by saying that Lyle Muller,
who was responsible for doing
that beautiful rotating traveling wave,
is on the job market.
So if you have a job
(audience laughs)
for a budding young
experimentalist and theoretician
and data analyst, he's your man.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
(inspirational techno music)